Дякую за інтерв'ю ви приїхали до
Німеччини якраз тоді коли Вона пообіцяла
надати додаткові мільярди на підтримку
України
тим не менше щодо одного з головних
питань чи надавати Україні бойові літаки
була в шоці дуже стриманий із скептично
ви вже довгий час підтримуєте позицію що
Україна Має отримати все чого потребує
Який ваш меседж на адресу що це щодо
літаків
Я думаю що ми всі у НАТО та Євросоюзі
маємо думати про те як підтримати
Україну
зараз найбільш актуальним є передусім
питання військової підтримки і ми маємо
підтримати Україну всім необхідним
устаткуванням усією необхідною зброєю
у нас Латвії немає винищувачів але
країнам які мають танки та винищувачі
варто подумати про це
знаєте
подумати чи дійсно надати було б щось
дуже близькі до того аби фактично
виключити такий крок
то це справа німецької влади вирішувати
це питання але я думаю що в
Європейському Союзі та нато ми досягли
згоди щодо підтримки України щоб вона
могла протидіяти Російському нападу а
також зібрати війну
Якщо у нас є ця мета то звісно кожна
країна повинна подумати про те що може
бути внеском кожної країни аби досягти
цієї мети то
вже було розроблено крок щодо надання
Україні танків Як ви вважаєте зараз
Україна Вже маєте що і потрібно аби
виграти цю війну українці кажуть Поки що
ні
а в когось Ukraine звісно Україна та
українці краще знають яку я актуальна
ситуація і ми покладаємося у цьому
питанні на Україну водночас дуже хорошим
знаком є те що перші танки леопард уже
доставлено в Україну як канцлер Шульц і
обіцяв раніше
Я думаю що Німеччина надає Україні дуже
значну підтримку Якщо говорити про
абсолютні цифри і так має бути і надалі
абсолютно
російський президент Володимир Путін
оголосив про розміщення ядерної зброї в
Білорусі як ви це оцінюєте І що це
означає для латві зрештою Латвія має
кордон як з Білорусією так і з Росією
для Латвії Ми також провели консультацію
з нашими союзниками тож усім канато на
даний момент полягає в тому що це не
змінює загальної військової ситуації
мілітареї освіти
Соул адже якщо говорити про ядерну зброю
то не так важливо де саме вона
розташована
адже її можна застосовувати з різних
міст але це звісно політичний сигнал з
боку Росії про те що вона не хоче мати
мир а хоче продовжувати агресію в
Україні
Латвії Як і всі інші балтійські держави
розташована прямо в цьому регіоні в
безпосередній близькості до Росії від
початку війни НАТО посилила свою
присутність у країнах Балтії зокрема і в
Латвії
ви вважаєте що цього достатньо чи вам
Хотілося би НАТО зробило більше
НАТО влітку 2022 року ми домовилися що
східний фланг НАТО має бути посилено
бути більше військової присутності і
найближчим часом ми матимемо більше
військ НАТО зокрема і в Балтійському
регіоні
але й загалом на Східному
фланзія
адже доктрина НАТО зараз Після цієї дуже
явної російської агресії полягає в
стримуванні Росії
за допомогою переконливої військової
присутності
і це інвестиція у військові присутність
є водночас інвестицією у мир
адже якщо Росія знатиме що друзі нападу
вона програє То вони не вирішуватимуть
нападати це
логіка яку ми маємо сприймати дуже
серйозно
тож НАТО і звісно Латвія але також
Німеччина зараз інвестують в
обороноздатність та посилення військових
можливостей аби підтримувати мир у
Європі
Але якщо говорити конкретно про заходи
яких було вжито в балтійських країнах на
даний момент ви вважаєте що вже було
досягнуто необхідного рівня
переконливості чи має бути зроблено щось
ще
знаєте немає когось конкретного моменту
коли можна говорити що його досягнуто ми
посилюємо військову присутність аби
Росії було зрозуміло що сенсу нападати
немає
і я думаю що ми в Латвії але і НАТО
загалом інвестують у більшу присутність
на всьому східному фланзі
Тобто ми маємо розуміти йдеться не про
атаку на одну з країн
НАТО - це об'єднання з 30 країн
йдеться про весь східний фланг НАТО від
Естонії до Болгарії
це регіон де має бути посилено військову
присутність а дуже скоро також і у
Фінляндії
мають також дуже довгий кордон з Росією
1300 км у нас 200 кілометрів
по салону має бути цей східний фланг уже
від Фінляндії до Болгарії на півдні це
наша спільна політика
Латвійська американська але й німецька
Алсу
але є заклики до постійної військової
присутності натов балтійських країнах
замі нинішнього принципу ротації яка
вашу думку з цього приводу
Так звісно постійне розміщення військ
також частина заходів із посилення
східного флангу НАТО це процес це
станеться не завтра але в належний
момент ми матимемо більше військ НАТО на
всьому східному
фланзіюпс сюди Ми маємо отаку
зараховувати фінські війська
поговорити про кита і Пекін представив
свій план з 12 пунктів зі своїм баченням
вирішення конфлікту що ви думаєте про
цей документ та нещодавній китайські
заяви
це покладаюся на оцінки президента
Зеленського та українського уряду
президент Зеленський сказав що він
позитивно ставиться до китайських зусиль
адже серед 12 пунктів один передбачають
що територіальна цілісність усіх країн
має бути захищена і її мають поважати
чого хочу Україна відновити свою
територіальну цілісність
тож ми побачимо якою буде участь Китаю
документів Схоже що Росія не зацікавлена
у відновленні територіальної цілісності
України але побачимо Бо Україна радше
позитивно сприйняла цю ініціативу
цей
принципами
із
позитивні
але Ми якраз побачили наскільки близькі
зараз Росія та Китаєм сідзеньпін
нещодавно був із візитом у Москві ці
відносини Мають дуже велике символічне
значення і Ці дві країни розділяють
оцінку що розширення НАТО призвело
зрештою до цієї війни Латвія яскравий
приклад цього розширення НАТО тож що ви
відповісте Китаю на аргумент аби
відкинути аргумент про те що вимовляв
частина проблеми
це фейковий аргумент
і це оборонний чисто оборонний Альянс і
це було б дуже неправильно зокрема і з
нашого боку вдаватися до
параноїдальної аргументації Росії бо я
не думаю що зокрема в Німеччині Хтось
думає про напад на Росії
це фейковий аргумент
але з іншого боку Росія напала на
Україну раніше напала на Грузію
це реальна загроза з боку Росії для
інших країн
тож це природна реакція вступати в НАТО
це вибір цих країн
Тож нам не варто вдаватися до цієї
фейкової аргументації
але Китай так само не задоволений
літай дуже уважно спостерігає за тим
яким буде результат російської агресії
проти України
якщо Росія отримає якусь вигоду то це
означатиме для Китаю що захист слабкий
Захід не може себе захистити Та звісно
передусім що США слабкі
Тож у цьому разі Китай так само матиме
інтерес розширювати зону свого впливу
передусім у східній Азії
але також і в інших країнах
інші країни у східній Азії дуже
занепокоєні цим цікаво що поки сі було у
Москві прем'єр-міністр Японії кісіда був
у Києві
І він сказав Україна сьогодні може бути
східною Азією завтра
Ukraine
крім того Китай не є сильно залученим до
війни в Україні
політично вони радше на боці Росії але
вони стоять з боку та спостерігають за
тим яким буде результат нападу на
Україну для Росії
на міцність для заходу для США для
натов
то що для заходу для Європи дуже важливо
підтримувати Україну не дозволити Росії
виграти війну та отримати з цього якусь
вигоду надто
Раша винзабор Самбір
Китай зі свого боку роздратовано тим що
вважає свого роду розширенням горизонтів
НАТО на Азію ідеться і про Японію і про
домовленість щодо розміщення
американських та британських атомних
підводних човнів в Австралії Китай у
всьому цьому бачать ознаки холодної
війни та звинувачує захід на чолі зі США
у шикуванні проти Китаю намаганні
стримати його що ви про це скажете
звісно інші країни не хочуть бути у
сфері впливу Росії чи Китаю
тож Японія Південна Корея дуже
занепокоєні через це
цікаво також що на останньому саміті
НАТО були присутні прем'єр-міністр
Японії президент Південної Кореї
прем'єри Австралії та Нової Зеландії
я думаю треба дивитися Де джерело
агресивних намірів це не надто це
зрозуміло
це російська ідеологія тут у нашому
регіоні але також політика Китаю
передусім щодо тайваню але також інших
регіонів у східній Азії
Я думаю що ми не маємо плутати джерело
агресії чи то агресивних намірів у
випадку зі східної Азією з політикою
пошуку шляхів захистити себе
і останнє запитання стосується США там
уже дедалі більше починають думати про
наступні вибори президента у
республіканській партії попереду всіх
Дональд Трамп які мають досить
ізоляціоністську позицію особливо не
переймається війною в Україні його
головний конкурент Рон десанттіс
намагається якось підлаштуватися
наголошуючи що це не в інтересах США та
варто радше переключитися на Азію та
сфокусуватися на Китай щоб ви сказали
республіканців які думають про те яким
шляхом має розви відбулася їхня партія
та схиляється до думки що Європа більше
не важлива
так подібні сигнали є У деяких
політичних колах у США
ідея ізоляції що США не мають
перейматися світом завжди існувала
Іноді вона була більш гучною іноді менш
Я думаю що більшість американців знає що
в інтересах США
бути присутніми на світовій сцені І що
Європа найкращий союзник Сполучених
Штатів
United States
адже ми бачимо що Захід Як ціле лише
один гравець у мультипулярному світі
тут я маю на увазі Європу разом із
Північною Америкою а також з деякими
країнами як Японія Австралія Південна
Корея
те що формує так званий захід об'єднаний
спільними цінностями адже це спільна
основа завдяки якій ми можемо говорити
про захід
тож ми маємо бути достатньо сильними
принаймні щоб захистити себе
адже якщо ми не хочемо відмовитися від
наших цінностей то це і є спосіб
захистити нашу демократію наші цінності
Тож нам потрібно інвестувати в нашу
оборону
Дякую за спілкування з ДВ дякую